this is really embarrassing for me
megan girl
i was gonna write a speech about how you
deserve this
but then i was like there's no way
they're gonna choose me
i was like it's hers billy eilish may
have won the trophy for record of the
year at the grammy awards
but she made sure megan the stallion was
the name
on everyone's minds you deserve this
you had a year that i think
is untoppable the bad guy singer opted
to use her acceptance speech
as a tribute to her fellow nominee
you are clean i want to cry thinking
about how much i love you
you're so beautiful you're so talented
you
deserve everything in the world i think
about you constantly i
wrote for you always you deserve it
honestly
genuinely this goes to her amid the
megan love fest
billy still made sure to shout out how
much the honor meant to her
but thank you also i really do
appreciate this
thank you to the academy thank you to
ringo i love you i love my team thank
you for
seeing me and um thank you to my brother
phineas and
uh yeah thanks for doing this i love you
thank you
is it weird that you i mean you have a
lot of grammys dude
it was like um yes so it's an
embarrassing amount
but it's an honor after the broadcast
billy's brother and collaborator phineas
quote tweeted their priceless reaction
to winning and wrote
when you're happily waiting to hear
savage
so what i'm really excited for is seeing
which artists are fans of other artists
the night's host trevor noah had
previously told dt the mutual admiration
was his favorite part of the grammys you
know what's what's been wonderful in in
the rehearsals
is seeing how even the biggest stars
are also fans of some of the music you
know so so for instance in like one of
the first
rehearsals i like i i was so surprised
to see
uh bad bonnie singing along to do a leap
her song like he was just like singing
in the chorus
i was just like wow and he's like i love
this song it's like this is
she's one of the biggest stars of all
time you know like one of one of the
most streamed artists on spotify ever
and here
he is singing along because of how we're
gonna be doing the show everyone's
watching everyone else perform so it's
almost like they're performing
for each other for everybody at home
which is a really cool dynamic